[Música]
Estados Unidos y Canadá avanzan en la
recuperación de los objetos voladores no
identificados que fueron detectados en
su espacio aéreo la casa blanca descartó
que se trate de extraterrestres en medio
de las especulaciones que han surgido al
respecto
inicio de México el segundo ciclo de
conversaciones entre el gobierno de
Colombia y la guerrilla del eln se
espera que esta etapa se prolongue
durante tres semanas durante las cuales
ambas partes intentarán llegar a un
acuerdo frente a un cese el fuego
bilateral
la presidenta peruana Dina boluarte
prometió luchar contra el
narcoterrorismo al que culpó de la
muerte de siete policías que fueron
emboscados en la región andina sus
declaraciones se dieron mientras asistía
al sepelio de los uniformados
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Estados Unidos la Casa Blanca se refirió
al derribo de objetos no identificados
en el espacio aéreo de América del Norte
la secretaria de prensa dijo que no hay
indicios de que se trate de actividad
extraterrestre debido a las
especulaciones que han surgido al
respecto el gobierno estadounidense
mencionó que no ha podido evaluar la
naturaleza ni el propósito de dichos
objetos Mientras tanto al igual que el
gobierno canadiense trabaja en la
recuperación de los restos para
determinar su procedencia
debido a que no hemos podido evaluar
definitivamente que son estos objetos
recientes hemos actuado con mucha
precaución para proteger nuestra
seguridad e intereses es por eso que
tenemos equipos trabajando arduamente
para tratar de rastrear los restos del
fin de semana tenemos grandes esfuerzos
en Carolina del Sur Alaska y el laburón
y estamos apoyando a nuestros socios
canadienses en sus esfuerzos allí
como saben la responsabilidad el
gobierno canadiense y de norat es
garantizar la seguridad de los
canadienses y cuando estos objetos no
identificados representan una amenaza
para el tráfico aéreo para la seguridad
civil debemos tomar medidas por ahora
realmente deben ser las fuerzas armadas
canadienses las que lideren los
esfuerzos de recuperación porque
nosotros como he dicho no sabemos el
grado de peligro que podría estar
involucrado en este objeto que fue
derribado y tenemos que estar seguros y
en otras noticias de Estados Unidos se
presentó un nuevo caso de violencia
Armada la policía de Michigan reportó
que al menos dos tiroteos en el campus
de la universidad Estatal la noche de
este lunes según reportes preliminares
hay varios heridos tras el ataque armado
según información de la portavoz del
centro de educativo al menos una persona
habría perdido la vida en los hechos
comenzó en Ciudad de México la segunda
Ronda de negociaciones entre la
guerrilla del ejército de liberación
nacional eln y el gobierno de Colombia
Se espera avanzar en los puntos
cruciales especialmente en el alto el
fuego para alcanzar un eventual acuerdo
de paz
en Ciudad de México arrancó la segunda
Ronda de unas negociaciones muy
importantes para Colombia las del
gobierno de Gustavo Petro con la
guerrilla eln cuyo principal objetivo es
el cese del fuego bilateral porque lo
que un gobierno acuerda para alcanzar la
paz Es un acuerdo de estado en este
sentido este gobierno hace realidad el
principio de que los pactos son para
cumplirlos
Y es que este eventual acuerdo de paz
con el eln es una tarea pendiente del
gobierno desde hace años que en
noviembre tras cuatro años de suspensión
consiguió reanudar en Caracas sede de la
primera ronda de conversaciones y en
diciembre llegaron a acuerdos como la
liberación de Rehenes y la puesta en
marcha de acciones humanitarias pero sin
alcanzar el alto del fuego también han
tenido desencuentros como cuando el
presidente Petro anunció el cese al
fuego a partir del 1 de enero para ser
desmentido más tarde por la guerrilla
que aseguró que no se a un acuerdo al
respecto tras aclarar los malentendidos
en la agenda de esta segunda ronda
figura el famoso alto del fuego la
participación ciudadana en el acuerdo y
el establecimiento de un plan de acción
definitivo cuya agenda Busca acordar
transformaciones y poner fin al
conflicto armado con la determinación de
lograr una paz integral y duradera ahora
se espera que las conversaciones se
prolonguen al menos durante tres semanas
cuando se verá si ambas partes consiguen
llegar al alto del fuego que sería
histórico ya que tras el acuerdo de paz
con las Farc en 2017 el eln es la última
guerrilla que sigue en activo en el país
entre tanto en Perú este lunes se llevó
a cabo el funeral de los siete policías
que murieron durante una emboscada el
pasado sábado en el sur del país el
ataque ocurrió en la provincia la
convención en cusco donde las fuerzas
armadas peruanas combaten desde hace más
de dos décadas a bandas de
narcotraficantes y a grupos residuales
de la guerrilla de sen la presidenta
Dina boluarte asistió a las honras
fúnebres y Desde allí prometió tomar
medidas para acabar con La amenaza del
narcoterrorismo
[Música]
una lucha frontal y la más decidida con
toda esa alianzas formada por el
terrorismo y el narcotráfico en el vraen
y en todo el territorio nacional
no permitiremos más muerte ni más
violencia queremos Paz vamos a Ecuador
el presidente Guillermo lasso había sido
convocado a comparecer ante la comisión
de la asamblea que Investiga un posible
entramado de corrupción en las empresas
públicas del sector eléctrico pero el
mandatario decidió no presentarse ya que
no estaba obligado por la ley lo que
generó nuevas tensiones con la oposición
esto se suma la atención política que
dejaron los resultados de las elecciones
en las que El Ejecutivo perdió el
referendo los detalles desde quito con
nuestro corresponsal Gustavo Ortega
bueno en principio se deben a que el
pasado viernes funcionarios de la
fiscalía general del estado allanaron la
secretaría jurídica de la presidencia
ellos luego de esto fueron convocados a
abandonar la presidencia de la república
Y esto ha generado también coincide con
un procedimiento de rotación que
defiende El Ejecutivo nacional donde se
rotan a los funcionarios luego de
cumplir un tiempo específico de las
instituciones del estado esto ha
generado también una reacciones no solo
por parte de la fiscalía que habla de
intromisión por parte del Estado para
evitar así entorpecer entorpecer los
procesos de investigación de igual forma
también habla de intervención por parte
del Estado habla también de acciones que
habría tenido algunas en instituciones
El Ejecutivo nacional se habla también
la corte Nacional de Justicia la
asamblea nacional habría rechazado esta
decisión por parte del ejecutivo
nacional porque dicen que estaría
interviniendo en los procesos de
investigación y haría mucho más lento
estas investigaciones en la supuesta
trama de cor pero Cuáles son los
escenarios posibles que se comentan
ahora en Ecuador se habla de juicio
político en contra del presidente de la
república se habla de la revocatoria del
mandato también se habla de la
aplicación de la muerte Cruzada son los
escenarios que estarían analizando en la
asamblea nacional que estarían
ofreciendo una recomendación un informe
a partir del 23 de febrero los equipos
de rescate de México que fueron enviados
a Turquía para prestar sus servicios
tras el terremoto rindieron homenaje a
porteo el perro que murió este fin de
semana durante las tareas de búsqueda en
la ciudad de adillamán durante la
ceremonia en la que también estuvieron
presentes sus compañeros de cuatro patas
los equipos de la Cruz Roja el ejército
y la Marina agradecieron al canino por
sus servicios proteo ayudó a localizar a
dos personas con vida bajo los escombros
y hacía parte del grupo de los 16 perros
Mexicanos llevados al país devastado por
el terremoto
en Venezuela el fútbol y el béisbol son
los deportes más populares pero en los
últimos años el ciclismo ha venido
atrayendo a cada vez más y más
deportistas actores privados están
tratando de desarrollar la Ultra
distancia una disciplina que tiene cada
vez más seguidores en toda América
Latina el informe es de cedric Ferreira
donde nacen los Andes
Venezuela se jacta de ser el país donde
comienza la Cordillera continental más
larga del mundo
es como un parque de diversiones para
los ciclistas más aguerridos increíble
el paisaje
Daniel y sus socios trabajan en un
proyecto que nació en 2019 crear la
primera carrera de Ultra ciclismo en
Venezuela como en otros países de
América Latina las reglas son simples
los participantes aficionados o
profesionales deben recorrer 1000
kilómetros en total autonomía en un
máximo de cinco días
el grupo hace antes un reconocimiento de
la ruta final de la futura carrera
Venezuela tiene muchísimos parques
nacionales Y muchísimas joyas naturales
para mostrarle a los venezolanos y a los
extranjeros que quieran venir a
disfrutarlas la verdad es que el
ciclismo de aventura es adaptable a casi
toda Venezuela
a raíz de la situación económica que
atraviesa el país el turismo está en
crisis desde hace una decena de años
pero en los últimos meses el sector ha
venido recuperándose por eso varios
patrocinadores privados ya están
apoyando el proyecto con la esperanza de
ayudar a desarrollar el ciclismo de
larga distancia creo que en Venezuela
hay muchos deportistas que bien lo que
necesitan es apoyo es generar equipo y
poder contar con el impulso para no solo
poderse dar a conocer sino para llevar a
cabo sus conocimientos y aprovechar lo
que tiene nuestro país para seguir
creciendo
en los últimos años el ultraciclismo ha
ido ganando popularidad en el Continente
en 2022 más de 200 personas algunas de
ellas provenientes de todo el mundo
participaron en carreras de larga
distancia en América Latina
hasta que este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]